bienvenido a la presentación del dominio
de una función en este vídeo te quiero
contar qué es el dominio y esta es una
palabra que usualmente viene de la mano
con rango pero ahorita nada más vamos a
hablar del dominio bueno el dominio de
una función es qué valores podemos meter
en esa función para obtener un resultado
válido déjame hacer algunos ejemplos voy
a empezar con este de acá efe de x igual
a x al cuadrado f x igual x al cuadrado
qué valores podemos poner aquí y
elevarlos al cuadrado pues cualquiera
entonces cualquier número que pongamos
aquí obtenemos un resultado válido al
elevarlo al cuadrado vale entonces en
este caso diremos que el dominio el
dominio
dominio dominio de la función f es igual
a los valores x que pertenecen a r esta
es una erre especial que tiene doble
raya aquí y representa el conjunto de
los números reales que son básicamente
todos los números excepto los números
complejos pero si no sabes que son los
números complejos no te preocupes
ahorita solo nos vamos a preocupar por
los números reales que contemplan los
enteros las fracciones y todos esos
básicamente todos los números de la
recta real vale bueno entonces este
simbolito son los números reales y esta
que parece una invertida representa que
x está en ese conjunto de los números
reales vale entonces cualquier número
real que pongamos aquí obtenemos un
resultado válido vamos a otro ejemplo
qué sucede si ahora tenemos f x
fx igual a 1 / x al cuadrado es lo mismo
que acá arriba podemos meter cualquier
valor pues qué sucede si intentamos
poner el valor cero aquí si intentamos
determinar
efe de cero pues nos quedaría que f de 0
es igual a 1 entre 0 y esta expresión no
está definida nadie se ha tomado la
molestia de definirla bueno a lo mejor
si lo han intentado pero nadie ha
logrado definir 1 entre 0 de manera que
siga siendo consistente con el resto de
las matemáticas entonces como la
expresión 1 entre 0 no está definida efe
no está definida para 0 y entonces no
podemos poner el valor cero aquí como
como escribimos eso en términos del
dominio pues le ponemos que el dominio
el dominio de la función es las x que
pertenecen a los números reales pero
ahora aquí hay que poner dos puntitos
tales que x es distinto de cero vale
entonces a diferencia del de arriba
arriba podríamos poner cualquier valor
real cualquier número real
aquí abajo pues no puede ser 0 ahí
quizás deberías decir estás llavecitas
estas llaves y estás representan un
conjunto sale entonces por eso las pongo
porque el dominio de la función es un
cierto conjunto de números bueno vamos a
un tercer ejemplo vamos a este vamos a
poner que fx
es igual a raíz cuadrada de x menos 3
ok qué sucede cuando intentamos sacar
raíz cuadrada aquí arriba no podemos
dividir entre 0 aquí abajo con la raíz
no podemos sacar raíces de números
negativos por lo menos no hasta ahorita
quizás después cuando hablemos de
números imaginarios vamos a poder sacar
raíces de cosas negativas pero hasta
ahorita no de esta forma lo que tenemos
que cuidar es que lo que está adentro de
la raíz sea positivo es decir tenemos
que cuidar que x menos 3 sea mayor o
igual que 0 o bien tenemos que cuidar
que x sea mayor o igual que 3 vale
entonces el dominio justo va a ser eso
el dominio
el dominio en este caso va a ser igual a
las equis que pertenecen a los números
reales tales que x es mayor o igual que
3 vale si x es 3 no hay problema estamos
sacando raíz de 0 y eso está súper bien
bueno vamos a un ejemplo un poquito más
complicado déjame tomar este color como
como rosa rojo y el ejemplo ahora dice
lo siguiente vamos a poner f de x igual
a la raíz cuadrada del valor absoluto de
x menos 3 uf ya se ve un poco más
difícil bueno misma idea que aquí arriba
necesitamos que lo que está adentro de
la raíz sea mayor o igual que 0 es decir
que el valor absoluto de x menos 3 sea
mayor o igual que 0 entonces valor
absoluto de x es mayor o igual que 3
pero ahora tenemos que considerar
algunos casos verdad que pasa o que
necesitamos pedir para que el valor
absoluto de que sea mayor o igual que 3
pues una opción es que el valor absoluto
de x
absoluto de equis o más bien ya lo voy a
poner en términos de x una opción es que
x sea menor o igual que menos 3 o bien
que x sea mayor o igual que 3 si ponemos
x igual a menos 2 está esta desigualdad
no se cumple verdad entonces x tiene que
estar tres unidades alejados del cero ya
sea para la izquierda o para la derecha
bueno entonces esto de aquí sería el
dominio el dominio
el dominio sería igual a las x es reales
reales tales que sucede esto de aquí bum
se va a este problema vamos con otro
problema
déjame a ver vamos a hacer uno muy
parecido sólo que ahora vamos a dividir
vale entonces va a ser 1 entre la raíz
cuadrada de valor absoluto de x 3 es la
misma expresión de aquí arriba pero
ahora está en el denominador entonces es
casi lo mismo pero tenemos que cuidar
que el denominador no sea 0 entonces
ahora estas desigualdades tienen que ser
desigualdades estrictas es decir debemos
cuidar qué valor absoluto de x menos 3
sea mayor que 0 ya no puede ser cero
porque no dividiríamos entre cero bueno
entonces valor absoluto de x ella mayor
que 3 y por lo tanto el dominio le voy a
poner así nada más dominio es igual a
las x es
que están en los reales tales que x es
menor que menos 3 o x es mayor que 3 es
casi igualito vale sólo hay que cuidarlo
de la división
muy bien creo que nos da tiempo de hacer
otro problema si todavía tenemos un
ratito más entonces déjame bajar
si te das cuenta como que este fue una
combinación de los dos anteriores verdad
bueno entonces vamos a hacer otro
problema en color azul y este problema
dice lo siguiente dice tenemos la
función f x
vamos a hacer una que sea por casos va
entonces fx es igual a es igual a 2 si x
es par
spar y es igual a 1 entre x2
por x1 y x2 x es impar
y un par muy bien entonces qué sucede
que esta función nos dice qué hacer aquí
arriba y aquí abajo por ejemplo si
ponemos un número para aquí adentro si
ponemos cuatro obtenemos que f de cuatro
es igual a dos porque cuatro es par vale
bueno cuando cuando se echa a perder
esta función cuando hay problemas pues
hay problemas con esta división verdad
cuando el denominador es cero
no queremos que aquí abajo nos quede una
división o que aquí abajo nos quede un
cero porque entonces dividiríamos entre
cero y no estaría definido entonces
tenemos que cuidar que que x menos uno
por x2 sea distinto de 0 vale pero
observa si ponemos si ponemos x igual a
no hay problema si ponemos x igualados
la definición nos manda al caso de
arriba entonces el caso de arriba pues
no nos preocupa no tenemos problema con
x igualados que podría ser problema
porque aquí se hace un cero pero si
ponemos x igual a 1 sí que iríamos en el
caso de aquí abajo y en el caso de aquí
abajo si dividiríamos entre 0 entonces
hay que pedir que x sea distinto de 1
para que no dividamos entre 0 muy bien
entonces déjame escribir aquí el dominio
ahora ojo el dominio únicamente son los
números que pueden ser pares o impares
es decir los números enteros entonces
voy a ponerle así es igual a las x que
pertenecen a los números enteros está
zeta con una doble raya son los números
enteros pero debemos de cuidar mira otra
forma de decir tales que es con una
barrita puedes usar los dos puntos o la
barrita entonces las x es que pertenecen
a los enteros
es que x x sea distinto de 1
muy bien entonces éste sería el dominio
y pidiendo que x viva en este conjunto
ya no tenemos ningún problema